would you be more focused on a task if
you knew someone was watching you with a
critical eye what if that someone was a
friendly robot or a mean robot to test
the effect of robots on human
concentration researchers gave 58 people
a classic test to measure how much they
were paying attention when there was a
robot in the room participants were
shown a series of words in different
colors and asked to identify the color
in which the word was printed ignoring
the word itself more focus is needed
when the word itself is a color word
than when the word is color neutral the
difference in the time it takes to
identify both kinds of words is called
the Stroop factor the subjects took the
test twice first alone and then again
with a new set of words in the presence
of a robot which was programmed to turn
its head as if we were watching them
right before the color test the subjects
interacted with a robot asking in a
series of questions the robot was set to
either good mode giving friendly
positive responses or bad mode giving
abrasive negative responses subjects
completed the test fastest in the
presence of the bad robot it was faster
than when they were alone or observed by
a friendly robot previous research has
shown the presence of a belligerent
human can improve our focus on tasks
like the Stroop test but this was the
first time this was studied with robots
as social robots become a bigger part of
everyday life for things like elder care
and therapeutics it's important to
understand even the unintended effects
that robots might have on how humans act
and think so while researchers don't
think robots will end up bossing humans
around anytime soon being a little wary
of humanoid BOTS might actually be a
good thing when it comes to focusing on
the task at hand
[Music]
[Music]